over the course of 10 years numerous
story lines and countless changes the
walking dead probably couldn't help but
leave behind a bunch of loose ends
here's a look at some of the major
burning questions that the series has
yet to answer
we last see a critically wounded rick in
season 9 injuring himself in a heroic
attempt to save his friends and loved
ones from a massive herd of walkers
what the other survivors don't know is
that rick just barely survives his act
of self-sacrifice and is rescued by the
mysterious
anne anne's allies gather the pair into
a helicopter to fly off to parts unknown
after which the show jumps forward years
later
with no sign of rick in the interim as
far as the other protagonists are
concerned
in season 10 michonne discovers evidence
on a grounded military boat that rick
may have survived the ordeal
among a host of scavenged goods she
finds his boots and cell phone
along with a log entry that suggests he
may be alive and is potentially in new
jersey
she sets off to find him now we know a
few things about the mysterious group
who took rick the helicopter he left in
belongs to the civic republic military
that group is advanced militaristic and
part of the alliance of the three
the group of fortified partner cities
which we've learned more about in the
walking dead spin-offs
so while we have a general idea of where
rick's journey has taken him the details
of what his life has been like since his
departure is still very vague
and we have no idea what the intervening
years have done for rick's circumstances
or his character
it seems we'll find out in the rick
centric movies that continue his story
in the years since rick's disappearance
and murky season 9 fate
fan favorite michonne has become the
leader of the alexandria safe zone as
well as the adoptive mother of judith
grimes
we last see her in the episode what we
become as she sets off north upon her
discovery that rick may be alive
determined to discover the fate of the
man she still loves
what we become has been confirmed as
being the last appearance of the
character on the walking dead
so we are unlikely to discover the
answer to michonne's fate within the
show as it wraps up its final story arcs
this is obviously an unhappy end for
fans of the series as michonne is a
pivotal and well-loved character so what
will become of her
despite the character's absence from the
rest of the series michonne would be a
natural fit to return in the rick
centric films
so fans can probably expect a resolution
to her story whenever those start
rolling out
another mystery concerns a fate of
eugene's group who were last seen
captured by a cadre of mysterious armed
soldiers at the end of season 10 episode
16.
the show hasn't revealed who these
soldiers are yet but the scene is a note
perfect recreation of a sequence in the
comic books that marks the debut of the
massive community known as the
commonwealth
in the comics the commonwealth are a
large well-organized network of
communities that attempt to restart
civilization following the devastation
of the zombie plague
it seems safe to assume that the attack
is our first introduction to the group
but the show has deviated from the books
that inspire it before
until the walking dead tells us outright
who these people are there's no way of
knowing for sure
charleston west virginia southern rail
yards about a mile south of the kanawha
river
one week can you be there when eugene
sets out to meet the mysterious
stephanie he approaches his meeting from
a hopeful place
after a long history of unrequited
feelings for rosita eugene is
understandably happy at the idea of a
potential romance with this mysterious
woman he sets out to meet for the first
time
when he instead encounters an unexpected
trap at the intended meeting he has to
be suspicious
is stephanie intentionally setting
eugene up for a trap or is it a
well-intentioned meet-up that's
intercepted in ways she can't control
from eugene's perspective there could be
any number of explanations
the comic books do show that stephanie
has a connection to the commonwealth the
group whose white armored soldiers trap
and capture eugene and company
yet eventually she and eugene do start a
relationship despite this frightening
experience
the show's take on this relationship
could go in an entirely different
direction
either way eugene's plans for romance
have at least hit a pretty major snag
two major series events rick's season 9
departure and eugene's season 10 capture
set us up for two major new
civilizations in the world of the
walking dead in the commonwealth and the
civic republic
what does the existence of these groups
mean for the future of the show and what
is their relationship to each other
the civic republic is an advanced
authoritarian society
and part of the alliance of the three an
allied network of fortified cities
including omaha nebraska
portland oregon and the civic republic
itself which is geographically around
pennsylvania
it boasts 200 000 citizens and stands as
the largest civilization in the show
world to date
the commonwealth is an ohio-based
network of communities with around 50
000 citizens and its own well-organized
standing army
it's a central civilization in the
comics and as such there's much more
available information on it
it's a thoroughly hierarchical class
system running in practice like a feudal
monarchy where people are locked into
the jobs they had before the apocalypse
while the two organizations are distinct
and should have strong roles in the
future of the show we don't know what
their relationships to each other
are as two of the largest civilizations
we've seen so far
each with large technologically advanced
militaries they're all but certain to at
least know about each other
at the same time the commonwealth of the
comics isn't a member of the alliance of
the three
since the latter group isn't a part of
the comic book storyline
how are these two organizations
connected if they are at all
the future of the show and its world may
lie in the relationships between these
societies
we just don't know what they are yet
late in season 10 we see the
introduction of a mysterious masked
warrior alongside maggie
wielding dual curved blades he's first
seen during a rescue of gabriel who's
barricaded in a hospital that's been
besieged by a group of whisperers
the whisperers barge in and easily
overtake gabriel it seems as though all
is lost before the masked warrior enters
and effortlessly slaughters the
attacking whisperers
the last of which is taken out by maggie
the only clue we have to his identity is
her cryptic line of introduction
which isn't very specific
it's okay
he's with me we know a few things from
this brief encounter the mass survivor
is a he a skilled warrior and maggie
clearly trusts him
other than those sparse details we have
yet to learn much of anything about
who's under the mask what his relation
to maggie is or
anything else about him really hopefully
we'll be seeing a lot more of him and
getting more answers in future episodes
virgil first introduced in season 10 is
still a very mysterious character
we first encounter him as a researcher
in the capture of ocean side
one who promises michonne a weapon that
will help against the whisperers
virgil accompanies me shone on the
excursion that marks her major discovery
of rick's apparent survival
leading to her own subsequent departure
from the show he betrays her trapping
and drugging her and causing her to have
a series of disturbing hallucinations
that betrayal serves as a prelude to the
discovery that virgil has also been
keeping
his co-workers captive for quite some
time she overpowers him and when
michonne discovers rick may be alive she
lets virgil live and sets off on her
journey
when michonne leaves virgil she seems to
see some good in him despite his
treachery and a history of having done
some bad things
is he trustworthy if not connie is
certainly in jeopardy
her fate and the response of daryl and
others remains mysterious
our introduction to negan comes when
he's the vicious leader of the saviors a
group who described themselves as
bringing civilization
and order back to the world albeit at a
terribly steep cost
whatever you do no matter what
you don't mess with the new world order
every community they encounter is
subjected to their rule
until a coalition of the alexandria safe
zone hilltop colony the kingdom
and oceanside break their power until
that time negan demands absolute loyalty
often killing a member of a rebellious
group to reinforce his rule and
subjugate those he conquers
early on in an effort to break the will
of rick and his group negan brutally
kills abraham and glenn with his barbed
wire wrapped baseball bat lucille
this leaves maggie glenn's wife
tragically widowed following the defeat
of negan's saviors maggie is
understandably angry at rick's decision
to spare negan's life
years later negan seems by all accounts
to be a changed man
killing alpha on carol's behalf and
actively working to prove his loyalty to
daryl
it seems at this junction that negan's
years-long change of heart is real
and is no longer in prison what will
maggie do when she finds this brutal
ex-ruler the man who killed glenn is
freely out and about
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single
[Music]
one